Imagínamos por un momento la siguiente situación.
Uno va llena el tanque de un automóvil con el combustible
de más alto octanaje, o sea, el más puro,
el que está diseñado específicamente para ese modelo.
Claro, el mejor del mercado.
Exacto.
Uno gira la llave con toda la confianza del mundo y nada.
Y el motor simplemente permanece en silencio.
Exacto, no hay chispa, no arranca para nada.
Es una analogía perfecta para lo que vamos a analizar hoy.
Sí, porque hoy vamos a sumergirmos en la historia clínica
de un hombre de 68 años,
al que básicamente se le administró el combustible definitivo
para la enfermedad de Parkinson.
Y resulta que su cerebro sencillamente lo ignoró por completo.
Lo cual, desde un punto de vista clínico,
es fascinante y, a la vez, super frustrante.
Era inmersión en las trincheras del razonamiento clínico.
Y hay que destacar que no estamos usando un artículo genérico hoy.
No.
Para nada, tenemos un material bastante singular.
Estamos trabajando directamente con el sílabo oficial
del módulo de Neurología,
del sexto semestre de la carrera de medicina
en la Universidad Central del Ecuador.
Un documento clave para formar a los futuros médicos del país.
Así es.
Y acompañando a este documento,
tenemos un caso clínico real.
Es un caso estructurado originalmente
para un debate socrático en el Hospital de Especialidad de Scarlo Sandra de Marin,
el famosísimo HCAM.
O sea, estamos viendo la teoría académica pura,
chocando de frente con la realidad cruda de una sala de hospital.
Exactamente.
Y para vivir esta misión de hoy,
no solo vamos a leer sobre Neurología,
sino que la vamos a actuar un poco.
Me parece excelente.
Yo voy a asumir el rol, digamos,
la estudiante de medicina curiosa
que intenta resolver el caso paso a paso.
Yo estoy lista.
Y yo voy a actuar como el docente,
asumiendo ese rol de guía socrático
para llevar el razonamiento clínico al límite,
que es exactamente lo que exige el sílabo de la Universidad Central.
Que entiendo que es bastante exigente con sus objetivos.
Bastante.
El sílabo pide integrar el método clínico,
aplicar un enfoque bióssico social y esto es vital.
Afinar el razonamiento anatómico
para localizar dónde está la lesión en el sistema nervioso.
Claro, porque un papel lo aguanta todo,
pero el paciente es un rompecabezas tridimensional, ¿no?
Exactamente.
Este caso es parte de la semana 11 del temario
que trata sobre trastornos del movimiento,
impartida por el doctor Alcitorres.
Y nos obliga a abandonar esa lectura pasiva.
Hay que meterse de lleno a hacer las preguntas incómodas.
Sí, hay que deducir que está pasando realmente
en el cerebro de este hombre.
Bueno, entonces entremos de lleno
a esa consulta del HCAM.
El caso nos presenta un paciente masculino 68 años.
Es diestro.
Un dato importante para la lateralidad.
Sí, y hay un detalle sobre su vida pasada
que resulta fundamental para entender el impacto de todo esto.
Él es jubilado, pero pasó toda su vida laboral
como conductor de transporte pesado.
Wow.
O sea, una profesión que exige reflejos impecables.
Contró el motor absoluto,
percepción espacial perfecta, todo eso.
Quien habla por él en la consulta,
la informante principal es su esposa.
Claro, suele pasar cuando el paciente
ya no puede dar una buena anamnesis.
Y el motivo de consulta que está anotado entre comillas
porque son palabras textuales de la familia.
Pinta un cuadro bastante desolador.
La esposa dice,
se cae hacia atrás a cada rato, está muy lento
y tiene la mirada perdida.
A ver, como docente te digo que ese motivo de consulta
ya debería generar una pauta analítica inmediata
en cualquier estudiante de medicina.
Por la combinación de los síntomas.
Exacto.
No es una simple queja de dolor de cabeza.
Lentitud, caídas hacia atrás, mirada perdida,
desde la semiología más básica
hay sistemas motores enteros que están fallando en conjunto.
Sí, es un colapcio múltiple.
Pero la historia clínica tiene que darnos la cronología
porque el tiempo en eurología lo es todo.
¿Cómo estudiante qué te dice la evolución de este paciente?
Bueno, la cronología marca una evolución de nueve meses.
Todo comenzó con una torpesa motora generalizada.
El paciente empezó a mostrar mucha lentitud al vestirse,
problemas para levantarse de una silla.
Lo típico que uno pensaría que es simplemente la edad o,
claro, Parkinson inicial.
Aha, pero el foco crítico de urgencia son las caídas.
Fíjete que en los últimos cuatro meses
ha sufrido seis caídas inexplicables.
Seis caídas en cuatro meses es muchísimo.
Y el patrón es siempre el mismo, siempre cae hacia atrás.
Lo que en el texto denominan retropulsión.
Y asumo que no son caídas suaves.
No, para nada.
La fuerza de estos impactos ha sido tan severa
que dos de estas caídas terminaron
en traumatismos granos efálicos leves.
Qué peligroso.
Y a la par de todo este colapso motor,
su esposa describe cambios drásticos en la conducta.
O sea, un nombre que antes manejaba camiones pesados
ahora está apático.
Tarda una eternidad en contestar una simple pregunta.
Un cambio de personalidad radical.
Sí, y presente episodios súper extraños
donde, de repente, llora o serría carcajada
sin ningún motivo aparente.
El documento clasifica eso como un afecto pseudovolvar.
Es un nivel de dependencia devastador.
Y, bueno, generalmente, un cuadro con esta combinación
de regidez y lentitud ya llega con algún intento
de tratamiento previo, ¿no?
Especialmente a un hospital de tercer nivel
como el HK.
Y ahí es exactamente donde la analogía de la gasolina
cobra sentido.
El documento detalla que este hombre
lleva tres meses recibiendo levodopa
combinada con carbidopa.
Aha, el tratamiento estándar.
Le dan dosis de 250 y 25 milígramos cada ocho horas.
Tres veces al día.
Para quienes nos escuchan, o sea, la levodopa,
es básicamente la herramienta principal,
el estándar de oro para el Parkinson.
Así es.
Pero el resultado clínico es nulo.
Cero.
No hay mejor y en la marcha, no hay alivio en la regidez.
Nada.
Le dan el tratamiento correcto para Parkinson
y su cuerpo simplemente no responde.
Y aquí, como tu docente guía en este debate socrático,
te digo que ese fracaso terapéutico
es nuestro primer gran pilar.
O sea, si la medicina no sirve,
el diagnóstico inicial estaba mal.
Exactamente.
Si el tratamiento no funciona,
hay que cuestionar la fundación misma del diagnóstico.
Aquí es donde aplicamos la discriminación
de las banderas rojas,
que es un concepto central del sílabo.
Ya, a ver, entonces dime la pregunta socrática.
Muy bien.
Si tenemos a un paciente con bradicinésia,
que es esa lentitud marcada
y una rigidez evidente,
que nos dice la presencia de caídas recurrentes
dentro del primer año de síntomas.
¿Por qué este simple detalle de tiempo
descarta virtualmente la enfermedad de Parkinson y diopática?
A ver,
intentemos desenredar esto pensando en cómo funciona
el Parkinson típico.
Es una enfermedad degenerativa, sí,
pero, digamos, tiene su propia velocidad, su propio ritmo.
Correcto.
El documento menciona la famosa escala de Johnny Yarr,
y, si mi memoria de estudiante no me falla,
en el Parkinson clásico,
perder el equilibrio al punto de caerse tan seguido
no pasa de la noche a la mañana.
Es una excelente línea de pensamiento.
¿Sigue por ahí?
Claro, suele ser un problema de tapas tardías, ¿no?
Digamos que toman, no sé,
ocho o diez años
en llegar esos estadios tres o cuatro.
Así es.
Tarda años en aparecer esa inestabilidad postural severa.
Entonces, si este paciente empezó a sentirse lento
hacia apenas nueve meses
y en los últimos cuatro meses
ya se ha caído seis veces de espalas,
pues la línea de tiempo se rompe.
Exactamente.
Caerse de forma tan temprana,
antes de cumplir un año de síntomas,
tiene que ser una bandera roja enorme.
Sugiere que el daño estructural es mucho más agresivo
o está en otra parte,
no en el área del Parkinson común.
Tu resonamiento es impecable.
Es el reconocimiento de patrones temporales
es la diferencia entre un diagnóstico erróneo
y un opresizo.
Wow, que importante es el tiempo, entonces.
Fundamental.
El Parkinsonismo como síndrome
agrupa lentitud y rigidez,
pero esta bandera roja nos obliga a buscar más allá.
Nos exige pasar a un examen físico neurológico muy minucioso.
Buscar las señales en el cuerpo.
Exacto.
Hay que ver qué más nos incinua la historia.
¿Qué encontraste en el examen físico de nuestro caso?
Ush, el examen físico que describen
es fascinante.
Lleno de detalles casi te atrales,
empezando por la cara.
El médico anota que el paciente tiene una fases hipomímica.
Una falta de expresión.
Sí, pero para visualizarlo mejor,
los ojos del paciente están sumamente abiertos
y casi no parpadea.
Registraron menos de cuatro parpadeos por minuto.
Eso es bajísimo.
Esto le da una expresión permanente como de asombro
o perplejidad.
En inglés le dicen el stirring gaze.
Y además, ahí en la consulta
confirman ese afecto seudo vulvar del que hablaba a la esposa.
Y esa expresión de perplejidad,
más la falta de parpadeo,
ya no habla de un fallo en los circuitos motores
de los músculos faciales y oculares.
No es solo un rostro sin expresión,
es una fijación totalmente anormal.
Sí, parece como congelado.
Y que te revela la evaluación del resto del cuerpo.
Especialmente el tono muscular y el equilibrio.
Ahí hay un contraste súper interesante.
Presenta una rígida esaccial muy marcada.
O sea, el cuello y el tronco están extremadamente rígidos.
Lo cual difiere del Parkinson clásico?
Exacto, porque una imagina que en el Parkinson,
la rígida se nota muchísimo en los brazos,
en las piernas,
y que hay temblor, ¿verdad?
Ajá, la rígida es apendicular.
Pues aquí no hay temblor de reposo para nada.
Y sobre la postura, el paciente está de pie
con las piernas súper separadas, una base muy amplia,
y el cuello está tirado se atrasco muy perextendido,
un retrocolis.
Una postura muy inestable.
Y luego le hacen la prueba de retropulsión.
El médico loja la suavemente hacia atrás por los hombros,
y el resultado es grado cuatro.
El paciente calla plomo si el doctor no la atrapa en el aire.
Cero reflejos para sostenerse.
Cero.
Y hay otro hallazgo peculiar que le llaman el signo del cohete.
Cuando intenta levantarse de la silla,
lo hace con un solo impulso violento y cae inmediatamente hacia atrás.
A ver, ese signo del cohete y el retrocolis
evidencia en una alteración profunda en los reflejos posturales.
La rígida es axial predominna sobre la de las extremidades.
Sí, es como si su centro de gravedades tuviera roto.
Exacto, pero el punto de inflexión de este caso clínico,
el hallazgo que nos va a permitir localizar la lesión exacta
cumpliendo el objetivo del sílabo, está en los ojos.
Y aquí es donde la cosa se vuelve súper compleja, pero reveladora.
El reporte dice que el paciente tiene una incapacidad casi total
para mover los ojos a voluntad en el eje vertical.
Es decir, hacia arriba o hacia abajo.
Le piden que mire hacia el suelo y los ojos simplemente no bajan.
Es una parálisis de la supra mirada inferior.
También le cuesta mirar hacia arriba y los movimientos rápidos
son superlentos.
Y aquí entra la maniobra clave.
Sí, el médico hace el reflejo óculosefálico,
la maniobra de ojos de muñeca.
Toma la cabeza del paciente y se la mueven rápidamente hacia arriba y hacia abajo.
Imágicamente los globos oculares sí logran recorrer todo ese rango
que hace un segundo parecía paralizado.
Bueno, estudiante, este es el corazón de nuestro debate socrático neurológico.
La presencia de este reflejo nos da la respuesta topográfica.
A ver, me preparo.
Pensemos en las estructuras anatómicas.
Si la maniobra de ojos de muñeca logra mover los globos oculares sin problema,
¿qué nos dice esto sobre el nivel del daño cerebral?
Porque demuestra que las lesiones supranuclear y no están los nervios craneales.
A ver, me tomo un momento procesar la mecánica de esto
cuando lo leí.
O sea, si al mover la cabeza los ojos suben y bajan por un acto reflejo,
eso significa que el, digamos, el hardware básico está intacto.
Muy bien, sigue.
Los músculos funcionan y los cables directos que los conectan en el tronco encefálico
que serían los nervios craneales están en perfectas condiciones.
Exacto.
Yo lo veo como una marioneta.
O sea, los ojos son la marioneta de madera
y los nervios del tronco encefálico son los hilos.
Si mueves la cabeza y la marioneta reacciona bien, los hilos no están rotos.
Me encanta esa analogía.
Entonces, el problema no está abajo en el tronco.
El problema tiene que ser el titiritero.
O sea, el que da la orden consciente de, oye, mira hacia abajo.
Y ese titiritero está más arriba en la vía supranuclear.
En el núcleo intersticial rostral de cajal, específicamente.
Y ese mismo.
El titiritero perdió la capacidad de mandar la orden voluntaria hacia los hilos.
Pero si activas el sistema automático agitando la cabeza, todo se mueve.
Por ende, la lesión está por encima de los núcleos.
Es supranuclear.
Excelente razonamiento.
La conexión con los hilos y el titiritero
es la forma perfecta de visualizar una paralisis supranuclear.
Lo que se está degenerando son las vías corticales descendentes,
las que permiten el control voluntario.
Y esto explica las caídas, ¿no?
Si no puede mirar al suelo por donde camina,
pierde toda la información espacial.
Exactamente.
Agraba todo enormemente.
Bueno, ya sabemos por semiología que la lesión es supranuclear.
Ahora necesitamos confirmar esto, viendo el cerebro directamente.
Lo cual nos lleva a la neuroimagen.
Que honestamente me parece un ejercicio de imaginación visual tremendo.
Los radiólogos tienen mucha creatividad, sí.
Tienen una nomenclatura curiosísima.
Porque para diferenciar esto de otras enfermedades,
el documento plantea buscar un patrón específico
en un cortesajital de la resonancia magnética.
Y usan figuras amigables para cosas tan sombrías.
Sí, en neuro radiología,
buscamos atrofias pérdidas de volumen precisas
y se recurre a las pareidolias,
o sea, ver formas conocidas en manchas grises.
Entonces, pregunta socrática 3.
¿Cuál es el signo radiológico que confirma este diagnóstico
y lo separa de, por ejemplo, una atrofia multisistémica?
A ver, el médico busca el signo del colibrí
o algunos le dicen del pingüino
y lo contrastan con lo que se vería en la atrofia multisistémica,
que es el signo de la cruz de pan, el hot cross band sign.
¿Qué parecen esos panecillos dojes con la cruz? Sí.
Es súper loco como usan un pajarito o un pan
para catalogar un daño cerebral irreversible,
pero llendo a la anatomía,
¿qué es lo que se encuje para que parezca un colibrí?
Bueno, la anatomía detrás de esa imagen es clave.
Una resonancia en cortes agital
es ver el perfil del cerebro cortado por la mitad.
Ahí vemos el tronco encefálico, el tallo.
Ah, el tallo que conecta con la médula.
Exacto.
La parte superior de ese tallo es el mesencefalo
y debajo está la protuberancia o el puente.
En este paciente, las neuronas del mesencefalo están muriendo
por lo que esa estructura se atrofia, se adelgaza muchísimo.
Ya.
Pero la protuberancia de abajo mantiene su volumen normal.
Entonces, visualmente, el mesencefalo encojido simula el pico
y la cabecita de un colibrí
y la protuberancia intacta forma el bien-tregordito del ave.
¡Wow! ¿Qué claro?
Y en la trofia multisistémica es al revés, ¿no?
Algo así.
La protuberancia es la que sufre daño
y crea esa imagen de cruz brillante.
Ver ese colibrí en la pantalla
es literalmente ver la de generación del titiritero del que hablámosos.
O sea, todo encaja con una precisión escalofriante,
el fracaso de la levodopa,
porque los receptores no son de Parkinson.
El examen físico con la rigidez, la mirada congelada
y los ojos que no bajan.
Sí, y ahora la resonancia confirmando
que el mesencefalo se está encogiendo.
Todo esto nos lleva la conclusión al climax del caso en el HKM.
El diagnóstico y que hacemos con él.
Y aquí es donde entra el enfoque biosicosocial del sílabo de lauce.
Ya no es solo un acertijo médico,
es una vida humana.
Bueno, el debnóstico final es paralisis su planuclear progresiva,
OPSP por sus siglas,
y determinen que es el fenotiporichar son clásico
basándose en los criterios del 2024.
Un diagnóstico muy duro.
Durísimo, porque no hay cura
y el plan de manejo tiene tres pilares.
El primero es reducir gradualmente la levodopa.
La idea es evitar la polifarmacia
y los efectos adversos de un medicamento
que no sirve para nada aquí.
Retirar la medicación inútil es vital para evitar toxicidad.
¿Y los otros dos pilares?
El segundo es terapia física,
pero con una instrucción muy particular.
Prescribir un andador especial con peso en la parte anterior.
¿Qué interesante?
Sí, tiene todo el sentido práctico.
Si el cae hacia atrás como un cohete,
el andador con peso frontal actúa como un contrapeso físico.
Una solución biomecánica.
Y el tercer pilar es derivarlo a fonaudiología
para un estudio de video de glusión.
El objetivo es buscar proactivamente algo
que llaman disfaje asilente.
Y esto subraya la verdadera pericia del manejo integral.
Verás, la PSP afecta a los músculos de la garganta.
Normalmente si un líquido se va a los pulmones,
un otose violentamente por reflejo, nos protege.
Claro, uno se aoga y tose.
Pero en la disfaje asilente,
el alimento cae a los pulmones y el paciente no tose,
porque los reflejos vulvares están alterados
y ese líquido causa neumonía por aspiración.
¿Qué suele ser letal en estos pacientes?
Así es.
Al buscarla antes de que haya síntomas,
intentamos prevenir la principal causa de mortalidad.
No podemos revertir el mesencefalo,
pero protegemos su respiración.
Y leyendo todo esto, hay una dualidad en el caso
que es profundamente desgarradora,
porque en la prueba minimal sacó 26 sobre 30.
O sea, no tiene una dimensia severa.
Para nada, él está cognitivamente presente,
comprende quién es su entorno.
Pero los circuitos de ejecución están rotos,
sufre disfunción ejecutiva,
y ese afecto se olovolvar de reír o llorar sin sentirlo.
Imagínate ser su esposa.
Te debe ser una carga inmensa,
ver a alguien tan vital atrapado así?
Sí, un hombre que manejaba camiones pesados
ahora atrapado en un cuerpo que no puede mirar al piso
y querría sin quererlo.
Refleja la brutal realidad de estas enfermedades
y por qué el sílavo insiste en el enfoque biosecosocial.
El médico trata una familia entera que pierde su ancla.
Ha sido un recorrido intensísimo.
Empezamos con un supuesto Parkinson rebelde.
Vimos como las caídas prematuras nos detuvieron.
Analizamos el diseño mecánico de los ojos
para hallar la lesión supra nuclear.
Tradujimos sombras en un colibrí.
Y terminamos en la paralisis supra nuclear progresiva
donde prevenir a ogos y retirar medicinas
es el mayor acto de cuidado.
El razonamiento clínico estructurado
fue nuestra red de seguridad aquí
y nos abre la puerta a una reflexión más profunda
para quienes nos escuchan sobre cómo catalogamos las enfermedades.
Así es, porque la PSP pertenece a los síndromes Parkinson Plus.
Y esto nos dejo un pensamiento final fascinante.
Nos demuestra que decir lentitud o rigidez
es un paraguas gigante.
Y bajo ese paraguas hay enfermedades
que son mundos completamente distintos,
estructura límolecularmente.
Lo cual nos obliga a preguntarnos.
Cuantos pacientes ahora mismo llevan años
con régimenes de medicación agotadores
que jamás les darán alivio.
Solo porque similan el perfil clínico superficial del Parkinson.
Exacto.
Es un recordatorio del valor incalculable
de no quedarse con la primera impresión,
de revisar el tiempo de evolución,
de mirar a los ojos del paciente.
Porque la respuesta que define la calidad de vida de una persona
puede estar oculta simplemente en su incapacidad de mirar hacia abajo.